and what does Taylor Swift staying here
okay well Apple is launching its new
streaming service in June the 30th and
there's a free trial so they're trying
to get some more subscribers more
customers for three months you can
access it free however that comes at the
expense of the musicians they're not
going to get paid for three months so
Taylor Swift has said well you know I
don't like this I'm not gonna make
available my 1989 album for you and of
course that's here one of the most
successful albums from last year so she
wrote on her Tumblr site this morning
and I think we've got some comments
sexually there that she wrote that it's
just unfair for Apple to do this to the
musicians and if you have a look at what
she's she's um said that it's not too
late to change this policy and change
the minds of those in the music industry
and she's just saying things like you
know we don't ask for free apple iphone
so why are you asking for free services
for musicians but she's saying you know
let's do something about this let's
change this policy not because she needs
to and she also said on her Tumblr site
you know she's she's not throwing a
tantrum here or trying to make life
difficult she's actually coming in to
bat for the smaller musicians the band's
those artists that can't make their
living just from going on the on the
concert tours and you get the people
coming to to their shows so she's really
using her power I suppose to try to do
something to change good in this
industry here well the industry has seen
its business model shift a number of
times an apple being on the back end of
this latest shift which is you know
streaming rather than downloading each
and every song yet that completely de
monetized a lot of things for the music
industry what does this mean then for
Apple and the music industry this new
business model and and what trick Taylor
Swift is insisting on well exactly as
you say so apples being caught a little
bit on the on the back foot here even
though through itunes apple is the
world's most successful retailer of
music and that Spotify the subscription
services some of the other small ones
are starting to encroach on that so
apple doesn't want to be left behind and
they're wanting to launch the Apple
music for
a 999 a month which is similar to the
Spotify prices 1499 for a family and so
it's really trying to get into this
share of the subscription streamlining
you know music online is not going away
in a hurry YouTube's biggest John relies
and access to to YouTube is the music
videos so apples really playing a fast
catch up here but not at the expense of
musicians says taylor swift okay